spend leading member of Nobel Committee
for chemistry that has just awarded a
discovery of quasi crystals what are
quasi crystals actually quasi crystals
are perfectly ordered materials that
never repeat themselves and this was an
absolutely unexpected discovery made by
Daniel Chester Minh in 1982 it has taken
a very long time for this discovery to
be accepted by the entire scientific
community and but today Costa crystals
constitute an entire area of science all
by itself spanning over chemistry
physics mathematics and material science
and they are very special how they are
very special because of their the atomic
ordering in quasi crystals in fact
they're so the atomic ordering is so
special that it took 25 years just to
find out where the atoms are and today
finding out where atoms are in a
solid-state material is is really a
routine task but in quasi crystals it
turned out to be a real challenge for
scientists of all branches they're also
very special because they have special
properties they have very low
coefficient of friction
they are nonstick materials where which
nothing seems to like to grow on
they are harmed they are brittle and
they conduct electricity and heat very
poorly and these properties make them
interesting as and useful as well but of
course a lot of this development will be
in the future what we have seen today is
that the combination of a low thermal
conductivity and a high chemical
resistance a resistance to adsorption
makes them very interesting as coating
materials in environments where the in
extreme environments such as on turbine
blades for example so can you produce
those in some artificial way
quasicrystals are most cosa crystals are
produced artificially they're the only
known natural quasi crystals are a
mineral from eastern Russia it is only
known in microscopic quantities the
first course I crystals were made in the
laboratory by Danny Ashburn and most
cosa crystals have been made this way
many cosa crystals are made by rapidly
cooling metal melts by taking a metal
melt and squirting it on to a cooled
wheel that rotates the high speed giving
cooling rates of a million degrees per
second and this preserves some of the
liquid properties of the metal and this
is this is used in many applications if
you cool even quicker you will get a
metallic glass and these have been known
for a long time and this discovery has
led to a paradigm shift in chemistry as
I understand materials chemistry what
was believed before well before the idea
of having a crystal that wasn't periodic
was utterly unheard of and our entire
theory for the properties of solid state
materials has been built on the
assumption that everything is periodic
electricity magnetism all these well
known properties are treated for
periodic systems when course I crystals
came about we had no idea of how to
treat these systems in terms of their
physical properties it turns out that
they do have very special properties not
they're not out-of-this-world they're
they have similarities to existing
systems but they are more extreme in
many respects for example the thermal
conductivity they're the the propensity
to carry heat is much much lower in
quasicrystals than in normal crystals
it's actually lower than in most glasses
so somehow the chemical and electrical
and heat properties they relate to a
geometry of the material oh they're very
much linked and this has to do with the
with the wave nature of most transport
phenomena in in matter we can be
described most transport phenomena as
waves propagating through matter and
waves are periodic things and these
waves break down in quasi crystals and
this leads to very different transport
properties and this has baffled science
for a long time but we now understand it
in a much better way and we are much
better equipped to tackle new phenomena
because embracing this paradigm shift
has I think made us a little bit more
humble about what we know and what we
don't know there's a big world out there
that we have very little understanding
although yet actually in two dimensional
systems in a flat surface this was a
question of geometry and mathematics for
a very long time since the ancient
Greece I would say yes indeed and it's
it's quite interesting that the the flat
Kozai crystals the the the two
dimensional quasicrystal they're
understandable in terms of the Penrose
tilings I have a couple of Penrose tiles
parts here and these are like jigsaw
puzzle pieces that can be fitted
together only according to certain rules
and generating a Penrose pattern
gives us patterns that we recognize from
other parts of you can show it for us
let's see so these pieces may be put
together in different ways now this is
not allowed
there are little markings on these
telling us how we're allowed to put them
together if we put them together
according to these rules these rules
force a periodicity a pattern that never
repeats itself and we can find such
patterns in old Arabic murals from the
medieval times we can find these basic
shapes we can find in in Kepler's
writings and we can find them throughout
history where artists and applied
geometries have tried to make fivefold
symmetry work and they had come very
close but it was not until the work of
Roger Penrose in 1974 that there was
rigorous proof that a periodicity could
be forced from a tiling pattern still
with that knowledge the world was
completely unprepared for the discovery
of Daniel Sherman that such a periodic
beasts actually exists also in solid
matter and even him couldn't believe it
from the beginning in 1982 when he saw
no absolutely clear from from his
notebook he he makes he makes a short
note in his in his laboratory notebook
and it's followed by three question
marks he was well trained he completely
understood what the Auris all was
forbidden and yet he swords and to his
great credit he realized that what he
saw was correct and what he had learnt
was wrong and this I think is a great
example of the science the way science
should be conducted we have to build on
prior experience but we must question it
at all stages and that's what he did
thank you very much stanley d